I'm disappointed not disappointed you're
doing tomorrow you're showing up in a
weave
come on you're showing up in a weave I
can see it oh that's it everybody know
everybody wins apparently except for a
Priya who's last in pretty much every
single category
wait why is the girl in the wheelchair
first
so when you have so many hurtful
experiences with Partners right and then
you got telling you you're perfect
you're the best you're the best you're
just like bro stop lying to me because
it's not helping me you're gaslighting
my reality obviously model like long
songs
yeah like just overall like beautiful
like definitely like get a very nice
body like hearing that from all of you
means so so much to me like thank you I
completely disagree
and I and I just like really really
appreciate that you have like my ideal
body type for myself preference so I'm
gonna switch with you
I don't know like I'm
this is gonna be unbearable what happens
oh my God oh my God no I'm not oh my God
oh my that's that was that gonna that's
what it's gonna be like you look amazing
get over here yeah I don't want to hear
it yeah I definitely want to move myself
to the end why why
I'm very short you know nobody cares
yeah dudes don't uh don't mind you being
short have you got it you got it I don't
know I feel like all of you guys are way
more beautiful than me you are petite
but I mean that's still you could be you
could have a good body type I think that
accommodates petite in a good one
accommodates length so I think that your
body suits you wait why is the girl in
the wheelchair first
yeah just throw throw away all the sorry
homicides to throw away the wheelchair
but throw away just throw away all the
pieces I'm like well how did that come
in my brain just being honest her being
in farts is just charity work yes it is
being someone who has had work done it's
really tough because like on one hand
you want to like please yourself and you
want to be comfortable in your body like
I guess I was I was comfortable I've
always been confident in my body but
like at the same time like you grew up
with all these things like being like
shoved down your throat gotten my body
done I've got my nose done I've got my
lips done there's this whole movement
going on right now with representation
but it's still I have such an unhealthy
relationship with my body because I'm
not supposed to like the thing that
holds me back from living the lives that
you guys get to live and I want to live
you know when I wanted to put you near
the top it wasn't like for the purpose
of representation I genuinely like your
body is amazing
why y'all lying
hmm
why the you lie
they know
they know they know they know even if I
take away the fact that she's in a
wheelchair even if you just you know
take that thought and you roll it out
the window when you really focus in on
what's happening
when you're really focusing on what's
happening it's not even like even if she
could stand okay
it ain't like like
her glutes ain't been used ain't like
she built like that
anyway to talk it just is what it
is I'm having to say it because these
people are lying on camera I don't know
what but sorry you know why we know why
about like I'll agree to like I don't
know
right exactly it's just like you're
genuinely like again like you know how
this is they put this
girl in second because she's curvy and
got a great figure and this girl got no
curves and they put her in first like
the consistency anywhere and we're
complimenting the other girl because she
had a fat ass in a small waist even
though she had work done so like it's on
it's like it's fine you know I mean it's
it's one thing
um and I know where it's from and why
it's there you know I mean because
that's not that's what we ask women we
ask women to be beautiful and it's
okay not to be
that's okay not to be true but it's it's
okay not to be I mean
it's okay you can keep saying it's okay
it's part of life their dating prospects
no your dating Prospect is not gonna be
the best well guess what we have to get
guess what we've been having to
deal with since ever if we was not rich
if we ain't got no children if we're not
like a certain type it was off
it's been off
so yeah it's okay
what's that meaning it's okay it means
it's part of life that's what it means
it means it's gonna happen because now
right now right now they're lying like
it's not happening like it's not a thing
like it's La La Land like it's just all
fairy and and there's like uh
Dustin Gold Dust every no that's
not what it is that's not a reality the
reality is not that that's what I mean
by it's okay it doesn't mean that yeah
it's perfect and then you're gonna get
what you're gonna get no it means that
it's part of life
tough luck some people get some some
people don't well that's why they go get
surgery because they don't want to
accept that so I mean saying it's okay
it's not gonna make anybody really feel
better no because at home like I don't
want that to be my rally I want a better
life I'm not gonna pay a couple of grand
I'm not saying I'm not saying it's okay
to make anybody feel better I'm just
saying that it's okay it's like yeah
yes
yes you're not the best and yes you're
not perfect okay you're not
that's what the okay means okay it means
exactly
yeah I wouldn't say that to somebody if
they say oh I'm ugly okay
but if that's your messaging to them
then cool it's okay to be ugly you kind
of have like the Natural Body you know
and that's not to say that like plastic
surgery you know is bad or whatever but
that would be like kind of how I would
kind of adjust that and then I would
switch with you because you have like
the more model-esque like athletic kind
of body type oh you want to switch yes
oh I thought it was going behind you I
feel like you should stay where you're
at
her where
[Applause]
over here
yes roll yourself to last please you
know what it is good good for her good
for her we love herself a self-aware and
you know why I say that too it's just
like her life experience has told her
what it is that's what I was about to
say so it's one of those things where
it's almost patronizing and insulting
when someone's trying to convince you of
her alternate reality oh you're the best
Queen you're the best she knows
ropes she knows what she's been through
yeah you understand what I'm saying her
everyday life doesn't tell her first
place we're gonna be right there telling
her no I relent that's not what her
experience is that's what it's like oh
thank you very much it's very touching
but I don't believe none of y'all and
I'm not gonna take that that's cause
every day she's we monitor that yeah so
also all this talk is just a bunch of
feel well but for real people
struggling they can't afford to live
like that because they gotta they gotta
move forward with their life
yo last time I took a plane this is what
they gave me yeah this wonderful little
bundle of joy the problem with those is
that you can't hear nothing uh it always
itches in my ear so you know what I mean
bash them away what I use now when I
travel is the raycon earbuds it comes
with five different types of gel uh
there's an awareness mode there's a
noise isolating mode as well so you can
perfectly ear the sound that comes out
of those earbuds and the other
competitors far too expensive we offer
the premium sound at half the price and
not only that but they're also water
resistant yeah so it's not even just
when I travel it's when I train too it's
water resistance because I'm sweating
and everything and stuff and they don't
fall off look let me show you
foreign
see
where you at go to the link in the
description below or go to buy recon.com
Abba to get 15 off on us if you were
someone swiping through an app and you
were looking at people based off of a
picture and you saw someone who was a
wheelchair user would you swipe yeah
hell yeah
being in a wheelchair like you a bad
she's speaking to society as a
whole yeah yo these ladies are just but
that's exactly what the I told you
in the beginning of the video it's gonna
be unbearable because they're going to
be lying to each other if you see a dude
just the fact that he's in a wheelchair
or you gonna swipe that's the reality
and that's why she don't believe none of
y'all because she deals with that every
day I already told y'all man when I said
the whole thing about zero match she's
like I've spoken to people with these
struggles doesn't mean they can't get
any no it's also very hard to get taken
seriously or because like there's the
idea of someone in a wheelchair but the
reality of living with them and dealing
with that handicap and having to adjust
to your partner you know at the end of
the day this is the truth you deal with
somebody who has a disability or
somebody who has a mental illness you're
gonna realize that the relationship is
not 50 50. it's not 60 40. it's going to
be sometimes 70 30 sometimes it's gonna
be 80 20. sometimes it's gonna be 90 10
it depends on how severe the disability
is but there's going to be an imbalance
and most people are not cut out for it
they start to dig in and they realize I
want out this so when you have so
many hurtful experiences with Partners
right and then you got telling you
you're perfect you're the best you're
the best you're just like bro
stop lying to me because it's not
helping me you're gaslighting my reality
you're making me think I'm crazy because
what I'm experiencing what you saying
are two different things if I go out
with a girl and she's in a wheelchair
we can't move in together
I gotta change my whole house
on my house I gotta change that I
gotta sell that and find something
that is suitable for both of us we'll
pay for a lot of Renovations oh my God a
lot of renovation my guy it's gonna be
yep yeah
no so and the way it set up so just that
if you just take that in concentration
any other people I could hop it so don't
deny the reality of the lives of those
people the life that they have and what
they go through I'm not often seen as
sexy in mainstream media as a disabled
woman there's not really a place yet for
people like me to feel sexy I think like
if we want to acknowledge the trends I'd
switch you too if we're going based on
society I feel like this ranking would
probably be pretty more accurate yeah
okay
probably
switch with you just because I think
like this is like who these clothes are
meant to be on if that makes sense
everybody's gonna wear them it's gonna
be her your style is cute but it's not
something that I envisioned myself
wearing I would probably move you back
to the front I would bring you before
her as well yeah because I'm so insecure
about my body I wear big baggy stuff I
don't feel like I have a body type that
I feel like I really hope after this
like you really like start wearing like
more like revealing yeah y'all got me
thinking I'm off for the hose okay but
reveal a little bit more your body's
beautiful I'm like you can see from a
bunch of yeah you know shout out to girl
the wheelchair she's very honest about
the fact that it's a struggle on that
thing and she's not out here just trying
to sell nobody on no positive messaging
about I like how candid and
Opus she is because I think a lot of
people don't know what it's like to be
in that situation so her being candy
like that hopefully lets people be more
aware
I agree like where we're at right yeah
I feel like I would switch with you do
you have makeup on I do yeah I think you
guys
you saw that right you saw that right
you thought hey
my little sister Priya straight from
India getting bro dude he
getting Savage this feels like that
other video low-key when the other girl
client girl who got murked they they
murdered this girl even harder oh spicy
my butthole is cleansing right now and I
didn't even have no Indian food I just
feel like it's leaking
whoa you just got a whole last leaky
butt right now yeah
why did you move to the end obviously
like I feel very beautiful in myself but
like when I'm comparing to like Society
that's like I do not fit I just realized
the first time I heard her voice and we
are two-thirds of this video done
she just been chilling in last place
knowing our place being like Indian
there's not a ton of representations the
representation that is there is just
like hyper like sexualized or like just
crazy like it's not normal even when the
representation for brown skin women it's
like when you think of a black girl
you're not thinking about me most people
still only like think like mixed or like
light skin or like you know like that
type of beauty standard like and like I
know like more recently it's become more
like popular advice like to oh melon in
this beautiful black is beautiful
because it's like marketable and it's
like a thing now like people no no no no
not because
Abba foggy the third has come on the
scene you understand me
your conscience has got to be connected
but your mind is on the coochie
sure politics got to be connected
put your mind's on the what
punani you didn't catch it you didn't
catch it the sermons need to be doubled
up because you've been forgetting the
speeches
we cannot allow our sisters to get on
live television with a blonde weave made
by an Asian woman in Taiwan struggling
to suck the titties of the what
government because they don't got no
money for these people so now we wearing
their hair because they sell it off for
slavery you understand
you're not peeping the game you look at
you brainwashed
I've been checking your head for
extensions proud to say it ain't the
case but my brother you're two steps
away from getting them done soon we
gonna have to call you preach Eric
Etienne what
I don't know I'm not following new you
the ancient name
they all got the same Asian name um
what people
huh what people
I'm focused on African history
don't come in here asking me about no
other people I don't come here asking
people I know the people when you only
got time for the black struggle it ain't
my job to be researching no Vietnamese
no part about to be part of China
country no okay I want to keep the
Asians Out of Africa and the Asians out
your mind now this sister here is lost
she got the baby hair why because her
mind is still childlike
that's why they call it a crib
because the baby never left the
institutionalization
I'm sorry
Hey listen peace and Pan African my
brothers and sisters I hope one day you
guys find the healing necessary through
African tribalism as well as African
mysticism do not be going to the white
man or the Asian people for your hair or
for your programming that's enough said
now please my cash app is below donate
for the school because we're hoping to
finish it by this fall I know it's been
five years but unfortunately we've been
working with some contractors who did US
dirty our own people now back to our
regular program
it's back to our regular unprogramming
because we unprogrammed the Mind from
the program
do not insert my authority in front of
the people my brother you understand
you've been harming the struggle for a
long time now I'm sorry and now the
first time you decide to speak up was to
undermine me I'm just saying hey hey
that's why you would never see Latinos
do that to one of their representatives
they would never do that in front of us
no they would not no they would not
they'd make a salsa song but they
wouldn't say that in public but all
kind can't help but snip at the knees
trying to us over in front of the
others I'm disappointed not I'm
disappointed you're doing tomorrow
you're showing up in a weave
showing up in a weave I can see it I can
see tomorrow you showing up in a week
you're doing the hair extensions
this leaves here about to be Miss
preached you can do the editing and cut
that out I would never cut out the
truth because they need to hear it in
its entirety they need to see what a
Trader looks like Judas
now let's get back to the programming
yeah whatever
whatever yeah whatever
hey hey and I never say that but
we got ourselves some hey you
know what they say even MLK had his
people working with the CIA just saying
yeah I don't know so like yours looks
more I guess like what I would consider
natural so that's why I would make that
switch Yeah
when like they want you to like go to
the end you're like you kind of get in
your head for a second thinking like oh
am I not pretty do they not think I'm
pretty do they not like this they're not
like that but it's just it's it's for
fun I don't think any of these women
think I'm unattractive I don't think any
of these women are unattractive I
totally wear Foundation to hide things
um you guys are just so natural I would
put myself back in the middle but I
think I would keep you there I like the
shape of your eyes and your face is very
symmetrical I feel like you're fighting
really hard to get out of that spot
we're going to keep you yeah we're
keeping you I told you we're locking you
in yeah babes
yes put the brakes on
I would totally absolutely move you
closer to the front because you know who
you are you know your beauty and you
know that you are beautiful and you know
exactly what to do to play to it
I I warned you I
warned you during something uniform I
told you that already I told you
that Hey listen my pan-african sisters
are all beautiful goddesses and they own
right straight from Nubia so I ain't got
no problem with the speech now Abba
himself that's some but
abazoo King the third
if the other one races want to worship
us that's fine it's fine they recognize
who the kings and queens was I would
have still had put myself behind you at
least you just know who you are I would
put you back up yeah I would switch with
you if it meant you could be up here
I would like one just because
here's the thing like all this talk
about overall Beauty blah blah blah okay
you know what we keep it simple
you make this an audience Voice who do
you think is really going first if I
give all these women a dating app and
give them equal level attractive
pictures who you think really getting it
and if we being honest it's not even
hard it's not difficult like we doing
all this pontificating I'm not even
trying to shade nobody I'm just saying
I'm very confident in what most people
would want to try to or date on a
dating app it's very easy the girl who's
on the far right she's tied for first
with the blonde hair lady that's just a
fact you put in get both dating apps
they gonna just crush it in a you know
in a western context black girl she
going down towards the bottom right
beside the wheelchair girl she's going
fifth not because I hate it I just know
she's gonna struggle on a date again
Priya gonna be third or fourth with uh
the redheads and ginger and I probably
think she's probably gonna be because I
feel like the ginger girl is probably
going to make more efforts to post their
straps so this
it's not hard I mean she she bought the
traps yeah I mean he didn't put that
much weight it's like she bought the
traps might as well post them it's like
bro I need Jubilee to add audience votes
to these things so we can keep it simple
because I'm pretty sure the crowd's
gonna look at these people and get the
right
it's gonna average out by percentages
generally having a disability I my body
is changing and it's out of my own
control and the thing that I can control
is the way that I view myself I just
don't view myself right
we are we are like what's going to be as
mean to each other than we are to
ourselves you shouldn't put yourself
down you should be your biggest fan oh
that's it every note everybody wins
apparently except for Priya who's last
in pretty much every single category I
mean it wasn't as dirty as the other one
because she got to speak a little bit
more on this one and she was hurt so
that was good but uh you know
she was last in every category and
honestly she didn't deserve to be
objectively speaking I ain't even mad if
they put her last is she really the
ugliest but I mean God damn